hey this is presh talwalker
five players compete in a table tennis
tournament such that each player plays
every other player exactly once there
are no draws in these matches in each
game both players have the same
probability of winning and the result of
one game does not influence the outcome
of the others what is the probability
that some player will win all of her
games
this is adapted from the Brazilian
mathematical Olympiad
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
I will first present the long way to
solve the problem by counting all of the
different cases then I will present a
short way by doing a probability sum
calculation so let's get started with
the long way
there are five players which we will
represent by five different nodes X1 to
X5
we can represent a match between two of
the players by connecting the nodes with
an edge so this will be a match between
players one and two
so the total number of matches will be
the total number of edges that we can
draw between five different nodes
we can draw this out and count it but we
can also see that it will be equal to 5
choose two because we have five nodes
and we're choosing two of them this is
equal to five times four over two which
is equal to ten so there are 10 matches
that are played
now let's color these edges we can color
and Edge blue if it's a win for player I
less than J and we'll color it red for a
loss so each of the different edges have
two different colorings so the total
number of possibilities is equivalent to
the total number of colorings now we
have 10 edges with two different
possibilities for each one so that will
be 2 to the 10 different colorings or
two to the 10 different possibilities
for the outcomes of these matches
now let E I be the event x i wins all
four of her games so let's calculate the
number of elements in E1 now from node
one we need all four of these edges to
be colored blue there's only one way to
do this
now there are six remaining edges and
each of these edges can be colored
either blue or red so that will be two
to the six different ways we can color
these edges
so the order of E1 is equal to 2 to the
power of six
now by the same logic that's true for
any of the other players so we can
calculate the order of E2 E3 E4 or E5
now here's a key part of the problem
e i and e j have an empty intersection
why is that
so if player one wins all of her games
since player one has played all of the
other players that would deal a loss to
all of the other players so it's not
possible that one of the players wins
all their matches and some other player
wins all of their matches it must be
that these are mutually exclusive events
so now we can count this
so we want the total number of E1 E2 E3
E4 and E5 divided by the total number of
possibilities
this will be 2 to the 6 plus 2 to the 6
plus 2 to the six plus two to the six
plus two to the sixth all over 2 to the
power of 10. so this is 5 times 2 to the
power of 6 divided by 2 to the power of
10 which equals 5 divided by 2 to the
power of four and that gives us the
answer of 5 over 16.
wow
so now let's do a shortcut and solve it
in a quicker way
we'll use the same notation as before
now what's the probability that some
player wins all four games it'll be one
half times one-half times one-half times
one-half because each of the four games
has a probability of one half of winning
the game so this is equal to one divided
by 2 to the power 4.
now as we argued before e i and EJ have
an empty intersection
so we want the probability of the Union
of E1 to E5
since the events are mutually exclusive
this will be the sum of the
probabilities of each of the events each
of the events has probability one over
two to the power of 4 and this is true
for five events so this will be equal to
five divided by 2 to the power 4 which
is equal to 5 over 16 and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time